die zehn milliarden euro die wir zur
verfügung stellen um die branchen-
gastro hotellerie aber auch
fitnessstudio um denen zu helfen weil
sie jetzt schließen müssen werden aus
den wirtschaftshilfen die schon
eingeplant sind finanziert und olaf
scholz hat keine steuererhöhung in der
korona pandemie und auch kein corona
soli vorgeschlagen sondern er hat
deutlich gemacht dass es unabhängig von
der korona zeit immer die debatte gab ob
nicht diejenigen die sehr reich sind zum
beispiel millionäre insgesamt besseren
steuerlichen beitrag leisten müssen das
ist aber eine debatte die unabhängig von
corona ist steuererhöhungen sind gift
wenn wir aus der krise herauskommen
wollen wir haben ja jetzt eine situation
dass wir wachstum auch reduziert und wir
müssen dieses wachstum anreizen das geht
nur wenn man erleichterungen schafft
gerade dann für die unternehmen für die
solo selbstständigen alle diejenigen die
jetzt unter schwierigsten bedingungen
arbeiten deswegen steuererhöhungen ist
vollkommen falsches konzept wenn man
darüber redet wir müssen über neue
entlastungen reden und über diejenigen
über die wir reden können über die
großen konzerne die in den letzten
jahren wie es auch christian winter
gesagt habe große umsätze gemacht haben
aber wenig steuern bezahlt haben in
deutschland und europa da müssen wir
darüber reden das wird die deutliche
mitsteuern anfassen können aber es wird
in dem anderen bereichen zu können
steuererhöhungen kommen
hätten wir nicht so gut und auch so
verantwortungsvoll gewirtschaftet
man könnte man jetzt nicht diese
maßnahmen flankierend zur unterstützung
einleiten oder wie sie bereits
eingeleitet worden sind
natürlich muss das ganze auch wieder mit
einem soliden abbau fahrt wieder
abgetragen werden genauso wie wir die
voraussetzungen geschafft haben dass wir
überhaupt holte helfen können ich glaube
es ist das falsche zeichen zu sagen
jetzt muss die bevölkerung ein corona
soli zeit
sie zahlt schon einen soli in vielfacher
form das muss nicht in euro oder
cent-bereich sein sondern in vielfacher
form was ihr leben eben anbelangt